all right hector you look great but
guess what's back
on 8 news now it's fruity 2d friday it's
a special
holiday edition with christmas literally
a week from today
i wanted to play an appropriate song so
i'm playing a song that we kind of
talked about a week or so ago
it's it's all about my last name
i think you know what i'm talking about
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
now if i could have i would have put my
hand over my heart because that's my
national anthem oh
tannenbaum means oh christmas tree so
sherry alex
thrilled to play the flute we all need a
little uplifting here especially in the
pandemic here but it's
it's also holiday time so we got to get
our christmas carols in there you guys
yes it is oh nate that was so good
we sure do oh tannenbaum beautiful night
that was so nice i don't know if you
knew this was going to happen but i did
not
and when i saw the flute i was very
happy so thank you nate i
i definitely miss
i do too we need christmas okay we need
christmas carols this time of year to
keep our spirits lifted
you know what else we need guys we need
ugly sweatshirts yeah we do
it's national hair day is that another
one that's a different one